.
Ein Waffelshop in Florida -
der amerikanische Traum von
Marina Marrer und Mike Hostettler.
Vor der Eröffnung
geht einiges drunter und drüber.
Zum Glück
sind Helfer aus Houston angereist.
Scheisse, kannst du mir schnell
helfen?- Stell es auf den Boden.
Bella Italia:
Ein Agriturismo
mit Ackerland und Gästewohnungen.
Eva Dudle und Philippe Sguaitamatti
sind als Liebespaar gestartet.
Dann kam die Trennung.
Nun soll aus Liebe
Freundschaft werden.
Ich denke, wir bemühen uns
um eine neue Form des Miteinanders.
An einer Stelle ihres Olivenhains
scheint der Boden unfruchtbar -
sie entnehmen eine Probe.
Zahltag in Frankreich:
Der Hof Les Aubiers samt Tieren,
Gebäuden
und landwirtschaftlichen Maschinen
geht in den Besitz
der Familie Wieser über.
Schatz, so schnell haben wir
noch nie so viele Traktoren gekauft.
Neuanfang auch für Sohn Gian.
Es ist Zeit, dass er in die Schule
geht und etwas lernt.
Einmal eins ist eins.
Zum Glück sind die Zahlen
überall gleich.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ein Frühling wie kein anderer
ist angebrochen.
Corona hat den Bewegungsradius in der
Grande Nation stark eingeschränkt.
Man darf sich
nur 10 km vom Wohnort entfernen.
Für die Bauernfamilie Wieser
kein Problem:
Ihr Hof und die Tiere
halten sie genug auf Trab.
Allez.
Auch die Schulen sind geschlossen.
Gian hat vorgezogene Ferien.
Statt Schule mit Landmaschinen
rumfahren - für die Familie stimmt's.
Gian weiss,
was er darf und was nicht.
Man muss Vertrauen ins Kind haben.
Es steht immer jemand bereit.
Ich kam vorher aus dem Milchzimmer
und hörte,
dass der Teleskop gestartet wurde.
Dann gehe ich raus oder Sandro
ist in der Nähe, wir schauen immer.
Ganz frei allein darf er nicht.
Jetzt kommt der Chefchauffeur.
Der automatische Mistschieber
ist hängengeblieben.
* Piepsen *
Der achtjährige Gian ist stolz.
Mit seinen Fahrkünsten
kann er dem Vater helfen,
den Schieber aus dem Dreck zu ziehen.
Für solche Sachen ist es gut.
Wenn ich jedes Mal mit den
Miststiefeln einsteigen müsste ...
Das ist super und er macht es gut.
Ja.
- Ja.
Einen tonnenschweren Mistschieber
wegzukarren,
ist nur eines von Gians Abenteuern
im neuen Leben in Frankreich.
* Fröhliche Version von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
Eins, zwei, drei.
(Alle) Yeah!
Für uns?
Von WonderWaffel Deutschland,
alles Gute.
Der Start zur offiziellen Eröffnung
ist noch verhalten.
Doch der erste Dollar ist schon da.
Das habt ihr super gemacht.
Das ist hier Tradition.
Aber es soll Glück bringen,
in Houston macht man das so.
An eine Wand tackern, das soll Glück
und v.a. Geld bringen.
Vielen Dank.
Arbeitsreiche Wochen
und Nächte mit wenig Schlaf
liegen hinter
den beiden Jungunternehmern.
* Geschäftige Klänge *
Hey.
- Hi.
Bald schon brummt der Laden
und die Mühen sind vergessen.
Zum Eröffnungsteam
gehören auch vier Studentinnen.
Es ist noch nicht real für mich.
Aber es läuft gut.
Gegen Abend
nehmen die Helfer Abschied.
Sie gehen zurück nach Houston. Dort
haben sie ihr eigenes Waffelgeschäft.
Danke, wir melden uns.
Schön, dass ihr da wart.
Nico, vielen Dank.
Kommt gut nach Hause, tschüss.
- Vielen Dank, tschüss zusammen.
Nun liegt alles
in Marinas und Mikes Händen.
Sie sind weg.
Nein, zuerst den Rahm drauf, Schatz.
Danach,
lernten wir in Deutschland.
Nein, das Loch ist zu klein,
das geht nicht.- Aha.
Nicht mehr reintun.
Jetzt kannst du
ein bisschen etwas reintun.
Nicht zu viel.
So, dass wenn man den Deckel
schliesst, nicht alles rausquillt.
Das ist viel zu viel.
Jetzt überläuft es.
Du musst sehr schnell sein.
- Ja, ja.
Gut, perfect.
(Frau) I know.
(Kind) I got two.
Thank you so much,
have a nice evening. Bye-bye.
Thank you guys, see you.
- Thank you so much.
Es ist fast 23 Uhr, als sich die
letzten Gäste auf den Heimweg machen.
Ich finde es inzwischen sehr geil.
Ich bin sehr stolz auf meine Frau
und auf mich selber,
dass wir das so durchgezogen haben.
Ich weiss, dass wir in der Schweiz
viele Kritiker haben, die sagen:
"Die machen das eh nicht
und kommen wieder zurück."
Dass wir es trotz der Erschwernis
Corona so durchziehen konnten,
finde ich sehr geil.
Ich fülle die nicht,
das ist Joghurt.
Nein, aber kühlstellen.
- Ja, ich bringe sie nach hinten.
Putzen und Kassensturz:
Fragt sich, wie viel
die beiden eingenommen haben.
* Hackbrettversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo" *
Es ist trocken und heiss
in der toskanischen Maremma.
Hier regnet es diesen Sommer kaum -
wie in ganz Südeuropa.
Die Wäsche ist im Nu trocken.
* Grillen zirpen *
Für die Olivenbäumchen
von Jungbauer Philippe jedoch
könnte die Trockenheit
zum Verhängnis werden.
Es ist etwas ganz Neues
und ich habe Freude daran.
Das einzige Problem hier
ist das Wasser.
Das ist ein massives Problem, weil
das ist der Grundstock für alles.
Ob für Pflanzen oder Menschen,
das ist einfach so.
Wir sind aufgrund der Aussage von
den Vorgängern davon ausgegangen,
dass wir
zwei Quellen auf dem Land haben.
Eine Quelle ist nicht vorhanden
und die andere ist versiegt.
D.h., wir müssen nach Wasser suchen.
Philippe Sguaitamatti
hat schnell mit den Nachbarn
Freundschaft geschlossen.
Jetzt in der Not helfen sie ihm.
Sie haben dort oben einen See.
Es kommt ohne Pumpe
mit Druck durch die Röhren.
Ich habe die Erlaubnis bekommen,
mich zu bedienen.
Er ist glücklich,
denn auch die Bodenprobe zeigte:
Die Erde des Olivenhains
ist unbelastet.
Strozzato.
Auch der Helfer ist ein Nachbar.
Ich bin gottfroh, dass ich
die Unterstützung von Giulio habe,
alleine könnte ich das nicht.
Ich müsste jemanden anstellen,
der mithilft,
denn das ist rechte Arbeit.
Es sind im Ganzen 800 Bäume.
Es ist keine kleine Rosenplantage,
es ist wirklich etwas da.
Philippe hofft, dass er die Pflanzen
nur dieses Jahr giessen muss.
Hätte ich vom Ganzen
mehr verstanden,
dann hätte ich
noch ein halbes Jahr gewartet
und im Oktober
mit den Oliven begonnen.
Dann regnet es.
Dann hätten wir das Theater
mit dem Giessen nicht gehabt.
* Rumbaversion von Göläs
"Uf u Dervo"*
Der einmalige Eröffnungstag
endet trivial:
Am Schluss
geht's ans Aufräumen und Putzen.
Manchmal, also wirklich.
Das gibt es doch nicht.
* Er ächzt. *
Du kannst ja ums Gebäude gehen.
Hä?
- Du kannst ja ums Gebäude gehen.
So weit kommt es noch.
* Marina lacht. *
Wegen den scheiss Ballons.
Ich finde noch nicht
alles ganz logisch.
Aber ich probiere es jetzt mal.
Ein Höhepunkt steht noch an:
der Kassensturz.
Wie viel haben sie eingenommen?
Das Schwierige ist,
dass ich für mich noch
eine Methode herausfinden muss,
die für mich am einfachsten ist.
Es gibt so viele verschiedene ...
Es wäre schön,
wenn wir 40 Kunden am Tag hätten.
Das haben wir heute übertroffen.
Darauf bin ich sehr stolz.
Marina ist die Finanzchefin.
* Der Drucker quietscht. *
Knapp 700 ¤.
Aber es muss sich noch rumsprechen.
Kannst du das bitte zählen?
- Okay.
Zehn und Münzen.
Das ist nicht meins,
das muss ich nicht können.
Eigentlich ist es blöd, wenn ich dir
zu 100 % die Finanzen überlasse.
Sehr blöd für dich.
700 ¤ -
ein stolzer Betrag für den Anfang.
Es gibt extrem viel Abfall.
- Das ist gigantisch, abartig.
Das gibt jeden Tag vier Säcke.
Wahrscheinlich stinkt unsere
Waschmaschine noch nach Haselnuss.
Deine Tasche noch.
Hast du allen Abfall?
- Ja.
Gegen Mitternacht erst
geht's nach Hause.
Keine Ahnung ich finde es sehr geil.
Wenn ich jetzt nach oben
zum Mond schaue, es ist warm.
Und jetzt gehe ich, sonst ...
- Yes.
* Reggae-Version
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
7 m Spannweite hat das Mähwerk.
* Gian summt eine Melodie. *
Zur Mähsaison hat sich Bauer Wieser
einen neuen Traktor geleistet.
Ich muss die Klingen kontrollieren,
ein paar Hektar sind bereits gemäht.
Die sind durch.
Geht es um Maschinen, ist Gian dabei.
Drehst du?
- Was?
- Was drehen?
Die Klingen, nach und nach.
Achtung.
Hinten sind sie bei mir ab.
- Warte.
Du musst es hinten anheben.
Hinten, nicht vorne rumschrauben!
Es ist relativ schwer.
Ach, das blöde Messer hier.
Wir sind ein Dreamteam.
Er ist der Traum
und ich bin das Team.
Manchmal ein Albtraum.
Gut.
Das Schöne ist,
irgendwann ändert sich das,
dann kann er die schweren Sachen
machen und ich die einfachen.
Gut.
Schon als Sandro in Gians Alter war,
wollte er Landwirt werden.
Sein Grossvater
hatte einen Hof im Appenzellerland.
Wegen einer Heuallergie aber
wurde Sandro Banker.
Mit der Zeit
bildete sich die Allergie zurück,
und Sandro konnte doch noch
seinen Traumberuf erlernen.
Mit 45 Jahren
ist er nun Grossbauer in Frankreich.
Gemacht haben wir jetzt gut 27 ha.
Total sind es -
die Hälfte haben wir jetzt -
54.
Und der Schweizer
hat bereits Expansionspläne.
Der Nachbar kam auf mich zu,
er wird pensioniert.
Dann könnten wir noch 55 ha pachten.
Dann hätten wir noch Reserve.
Wir sind jetzt mit der Fläche
gegenüber der Anzahl Tiere just.
Aber nur die Flächen.
Wenn sie gegenüber
der eigenen Felder liegen,
dann muss man nicht lange überlegen.
* Rockige Version
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
Einmal mehr wird es ein langer Tag.
Und morgen in aller Früh
geht's schon wieder weiter.
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Bella Italia -
Sonne, Strand und Meer.
Eine Viertelstunde von der Küste
entfernt, im ruhigen Hinterland,
wollen zwei Zürcher
Ferien auf dem Bauernhof anbieten.
Ein Agriturismo mit sechs
Ferienwohnungen und Swimmingpool.
* Gelassene Gitarrenklänge *
Eva hat Ferien.
Die Kindergartenlehrerin
ist ein wenig überrumpelt:
Morgen kommen zwei Töchter
samt Familien zu Besuch.
Und dann haben sich unerwartet
vier weitere Gäste angemeldet.
Der Nachbar
hat ihr Agriturismo empfohlen.
Noch aber fehlen Töpfe und Möbel.
Es hat noch
einen unrealistischen Touch ...
Es ist noch so viel zu tun,
bis sie kommen.
Ich weiss nicht, ob ich es schaffe.
Nachdem wir wussten,
dass wir hierhin kommen,
habe ich immer wieder Sachen,
die ich gerade gesehen habe,
gekauft.
Und in einem Storage gestapelt.
Dort haben wir alles gestapelt.
Wenn ich in ein Hotel komme,
regt es mich auf,
wenn es ekelige, verkratzte Töpfe
mit so einem Boden hat.
Das mache ich nicht,
das bringe ich nicht übers Herz,
bei mir gibt es ordentliche Sachen.
Die beiden
haben sich zusammengerauft.
Voilà, Madame.
Wo willst du die hintun?
Die muss man noch abwaschen.
Und es funktioniert:
Philippe hat Zeit, ist vor Ort.
Eva brachte das Kapital ein
und arbeitet während der Ferien
auf dem Gut.
Einmal Zwetschge.
Ist es gut?
- Ja.
Super.
Wir könnten
eine Montagefirma eröffnen.
Aber nicht mehr in diesem Leben,
im nächsten dann.
Manchmal nervt sie,
aber das tue ich wohl auch.
Oder?
- Ja, ja.
Das ist wohl einfach so.
- Ich wusste es.
Ich finde es gut, wenn man nicht
die ganze Zeit aufeinandersitzt.
Deswegen finde ich es
eine gute Lösung,
dass ich z.T.
noch in der Schweiz bin.
Ich denke, ich habe beides.
Und für Philippe stimmt es sehr,
hier unten zu leben.
Ich denke, es ist für beide
eine Win-win-Situation.
Tatsächlich - für Philippe stimmt's.
In Italien ist er nicht nur Bauer,
sondern auch noch Gastgeber.
Salve.
- Salve.
Ob reguläre Gäste
oder die eigenen Kinder -
Eva hat hohe Ansprüche
an ihre Gastfreundschaft.
Die Seele muss sich
zu Hause fühlen können.
Das ist für mich sehr wichtig.
Ich will kein Kommerzunternehmen,
ich will etwas machen,
wo Leute zur Ruhe kommen können.
Man soll in ein Haus kommen
und sich wohlfühlen können.
Sich für ein paar Wochen
niederlassen
und sich einfach wohlfühlen.
* Entspannte Klänge *
Wir haben wirklich
hart dafür gearbeitet.
Eva genauso wie ich.
Das haben wir wirklich.
Dass wir jetzt gleich vier haben,
die kommen und glücklich sind,
das finde ich genial.
* Reggae-Version
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
* Die Musik verklingt. *
Zehn Wochen sind seit
der gelungenen Eröffnung vergangen.
Mit jedem Tag sind Marina und Mike
routinierter geworden
und sind im amerikanischen Alltag
angekommen.
Marina macht eine kleine Morgenrunde
mit Hündin Djuna.
Mike pflegt den Vorgarten - ein Muss.
Denn auch das Land
der unbegrenzten Möglichkeiten
kennt überraschende Grenzen.
Man muss nach den Sachen schauen,
es muss sauber sein.
Das County schickt wöchentlich -
am Dienstag oder Mittwoch -
jemanden vorbei, der schaut,
ob alles gut ist,
ob der Rasen gemäht ist.
Wenn etwas nicht gut ist,
bekommt man ein Schreiben,
eine Penalty, eine Busse von 50 ¤.
Der Morgenspaziergang ist der
einzige Moment der Ruhe für Marina.
Die beiden arbeiten unablässig.
14 Std. täglich,
sieben Tage die Woche.
Er will bestimmt einen Chai Latte.
Ich brauche einfach immer
eine Herausforderung.
Ich glaube,
hier werde ich sie immer haben.
Vielleicht nicht vom Produkt
und der Zubereitung her,
eher wegen allem,
was dahintersteckt,
wenn man ein Unternehmen
selbst führt.
Bis jetzt ist es mir noch nicht
verleidet, ich hoffe, es bleibt so.
Auf den Herbst hat Marina
eine eigene Waffel kreiert:
die Halloweenwaffel
mit einer Sauce aus Äpfeln, Bananen,
Zimt, Kondensmilch und Kürbis.
Es ist so, dass man alles mit
dem Franchisegeber absprechen muss.
Wir haben ihnen das Rezept
und ein Foto geschickt,
und die waren hell begeistert,
es sehe super aus.
* Geschäftige Klänge *
You can have the waffel with:
Hershey's, Reese's, Oreos, Twix,
Snickers, KitKat, Gummy Bears,
M&M's, Kinder Bueno, Kinder Riegel,
Raffaelo, Ferrero Rocher.
Und doch, trotz Begeisterung
und noch mehr Herzblut:
Ihr Alltag ist kräfteraubend.
Im Moment heisst es
arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten
und noch einmal arbeiten.
Das wird irgendwann anders.
Unser grösstes Problem ist es,
Mitarbeiter zu finden,
die zuverlässig sind.
Dann hat man das Gefühl,
dass sie zuverlässig sind,
in der Woche darauf
ist es dann das pure Gegenteil.
Bei uns
ist es momentan etwas stressig,
allem gerecht werden zu können.
* Akkordeonversion
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
Viel Arbeit auch in Frankreich:
Es herrscht Hochbetrieb.
Ist das Gras gemäht,
wird es unverzüglich gehäckselt
und in Silos eingelagert.
Mitarbeiter und Bauern aus der Gegend
unterstützen Sandro.
Jetzt haben wir gut 55 ha Gras
am Boden.
Ja.
Bis um 2 Uhr in der Nacht
und gestern bis um 3 Uhr ...
Das ist ja nicht der Alltag.
In der Schweiz
hatte Sandro Rundballensilos.
Hier konserviert er das Tierfutter
in einem flachen Fahrsilo.
Es ist das erste Mal, ich bin
gespannt, wie das funktioniert.
Also, ich weiss ja, wie es geht.
Aber wie der Workflow ist.
Das wird schon gut.
Wird gut.
Bringst du Guy noch einen Kaffee?
- Bonjour.
Sandro gönnt sich keine Pause.
Die Anhänger und der Häcksler
gehören einer Kooperative.
Eine Bauerngemeinschaft, die sich
Maschinen und Arbeitskraft teilt.
Später wird auch Sandro
den anderen Bauern helfen.
Komm, du hast die Kiste voll.
Es schneit.
Trotz der vielen Arbeit -
Sandro passt's.
Ja.
Es darf so weitergehen.
Träumen darf man ja,
für die Realität
ist man selber verantwortlich.
* Akkordeonversion
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
In der Schweiz silierte Sandro
300 t Gras im Jahr.
Hier sind es fünfmal so viele -
nebst 4'000 t Mais.
In der Toskana
herrscht fast schon Hochstimmung.
Die ersten Gäste sind da.
Und morgen schon kommen Evas Töchter
und Enkelkinder an.
Bettwäsche.
Die an der Kasse war genervt,
es hat nicht mehr aufgehört.
Heute haben die Zürcher
ihre italienischen Freunde
zu einem Grillabend eingeladen.
Si, vieni, ciao, Cordelia.
- Ciao, Cordelia.
Bene.
Doch dann ruft Evas Tochter an.
* Klingelton *
Jetzt klingelt auch noch
mein Telefon.
Theresia.
Hoi.
- Und, tutto bene?
No.
Was ist nicht bene?
- Wir haben einen Coronafall.- Wer?
Mein Mann.
- Okay.
Er musste einen PCR-Test machen.
Ich habe weinende Kinder zu Hause,
das ist nicht so lustig.
Oh, nein!
(Martina) Bene.
(Weinerlich) Ich könnte weinen.
- Was ist los?
Marcel ist positiv.
Positiv?
- Corona-positiv.
Ich habe mich so gefreut,
dass ihr kommt.
Aber ihr kommt dann,
wenn es vorbei ist.
Ja.
- Super, tschüss, tschau, tschau.
Hoi, wir haben einen Coronafall.
- Ich habe es gehört. Wer?
Mein Schwiegersohn,
sie sassen schon im Auto
und dann kam die SMS,
dass er positiv sei.
Sie sind gleich zurückgefahren.
Ciao, Lino.
- Ciao.
Alle helfen mit.
Allora, was können wir machen?
Ihr könntet draussen
den Tisch decken.
* Teller klappern. *
Zwei.
* Brutzeln *
Meine Lieblingsbeschäftigung.
Und Cordelia hat mir noch gezeigt,
wie man das richtig macht
mit Öl, Salz
und Rosmarin, das riecht gut.
Ich lerne jeden Tag so viel Neues
dazu - unglaublich.
Diese Sachen freuen mich so.
Das gibt mir Antrieb
und motiviert mich wahnsinnig.
* Gelassene Klänge *
Gelebte Italianità - so wie es sich
die Zürcher vorgestellt haben.
Ich war etwas gestresst,
aber jeder hat mitgeholfen.
Es ist für mich sehr berührend.
Das ist für mich Familiengefühl.
So ist es auch bei mir zu Hause,
wenn etwas ist, hilft jeder
von meinen Söhnen und Töchtern.
Das ist auch hier ein
familiäres Gefühl mit diesen Leuten.
* Rumba-Version
von Göläs "Uf u Dervo" *
Wieder steckt den Jungunternehmern
ein 14-Std.-Tag in den Knochen.
Erst gegen 23 Uhr sind sie zu Hause.
Ein Fondue?
- Ein Fondue.
Hoppala.
Mit einem Tierkanal
bei guter Laune gehalten ist Djuna.
Wenn die Hundesitterin geht, lässt
sie für die Hündin den TV laufen.
Willst du heute
wieder mal Weingläser?
Aber bitte die für die Spülmaschine.
Seit bald einem Jahr ist das Haus
am Cottontail Place das Zuhause
der Florida-Auswanderer.
Das musst du noch auffüllen,
letztes Mal war es plötzlich aus.
Prost.
Es fehlt uns,
zwischendurch Freunde zu treffen.
Oder Zweisamkeit.
Freunde
werden im Moment vernachlässigt.
Aber die kommen ab und zu
in den Laden und essen eine Waffel.
Genau.
Marina hat das Schweizer Fondue
bereits den amerikanischen
Verhältnissen angepasst:
Als Beilage gibt es Süsskartoffeln.
Wir haben in der Schweiz nie
so viel Fondue gegessen wie hier.
Heimweh.
- Ach.
Ich weiss, du hörst das nicht gerne,
aber es ist Heimweh.
Es ist ein Stück Schweiz.
- Heimat.
Selbst wenn das seit Jahren
ein Traum von mir ist.
Selbst wenn wir
hier in Amerika leben,
wir sind immer noch Schweizer.
Wir sind keine Amerikaner,
wir bleiben Schweizer.
Djuni.
Es brennt.
* Langsame, lateinamerikanisch
angehauchte E-Gitarrenklänge *
Mir fehlt v.a. meine Familie.
Damit habe
ich am meisten zu kämpfen.
Sie sind 24 Std. zusammen,
Abwechslung haben sie kaum.
Dazu kommt der Stress im Geschäft -
eine stete Herausforderung
für das Paar.
Auch wir haben mal Streit und sind
nicht immer der gleichen Meinung.
Aber das gehört zum Leben dazu.
Egal, ob Freundschaft,
Beziehung, Geschäftspartner.
Ich glaube,
wir haben die Balance gefunden
zwischen Geschäfts- und Ehepartnern.
Ich glaube, wir haben sie gefunden.
Die Mähsaison
ist auch für Aleksandra anstrengend.
Schon um 5 Uhr
stand sie im Stall und melkte.
Jetzt kocht sie
für die Männer auf dem Feld.
Sie haben Hunger,
die armen Männer im Traktor.
Wenn sie nächste Woche
bei einem anderen Bauern sind,
dann kocht die Frau dort zu Mittag.
Viele gehen auch ins Restaurant,
das geht schneller.
Vielleicht arbeitet die Frau auch.
Es wird immer so abgewechselt.
Gastgeberin Aleksandra
hat mit der klassischen
Rollenverteilung keine Mühe.
Was sie mehr ärgert,
ist das Französisch.
Ich klopfe gerne Sprüche.
So kennt man mich eben.
Das ist im Moment nicht so möglich,
weil die Sprache
noch nicht so richtig da ist.
Gewisse Sprüche
kann ich schon raushauen.
Aber es fehlt ein wenig.
Zu Mittag gibt es
etwas typisch Schweizerisches:
Fleischkäse.
Ein Gericht,
das den Franzosen fremd ist.
Die Gebrüder Rondeau, einst
Hofbesitzer, sind nun Wiesers Gäste.
Bonjour.
Doch die Begeisterung
für die Schweizer Küche
hält sich bei den Franzosen
in Grenzen.
Vielleicht sind auch alle nur müde.
Zum Kaffee reicht die Gastgeberin
selbstgemachten Kuchen.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Einzelne Gitarrenakkorde *
Die Dürreperiode hält an.
Seit Wochen schon
kein einziger Tropfen Regen.
Würden die jungen Bäumchen
nicht bewässert -
sie würden den Sommer kaum überleben.
Die Zürcher dürfen den Wasserspeicher
einer Nachbarin anzapfen.
Dieser gehört zu einem Agriturismo,
das Oliven und Weintrauben anbaut.
Die Jungbauern sind zu Besuch
bei der Besitzerin des Guts
und bedanken sich
für ihre Unterstützung.
Allora.
Ci vediamo un'altra volta, grazie.
- Si, grazie.
Trotz Martas Grosszügigkeit ...
Ciao!
- Ciao.
... den Zürchern
ist sehr wohl bewusst,
dass sie dringend einen eigenen
Grundwasserbrunnen brauchen.
Doch die unerwarteten Ausgaben
bringen ihr Budget durcheinander.
Um als Agriturismo zu gelten,
müssen Arbeitsaufwand und Einnahmen
aus der Landwirtschaft höher sein
als aus dem Gästebetrieb.
Heisst also, sie müssen noch mehr
von ihrem Land beackern.
Der Gästebetrieb ist angelaufen.
Hier lässt sich schon mal
ein wenig Geld verdienen.
Aber das reicht noch nicht.
Ihr Steuerexperte
ist zu einer Beratung gekommen.
In die Ferienhäuschen
muss investiert werden -
noch fehlen in fünf Wohnungen Küchen.
Doch auch das kostet.
Albertos Rat ist simpel:
Ein Kredit müsse aufgenommen werden.
Ich würde Schulden machen.
- Jetzt mal zum Starten?
Das liebe Geld.
Puncto Geld könnten Eva und Phillipe
kaum unterschiedlicher ticken.
Einen Kredit aufnehmen,
das entspricht in keiner Weise
Evas Philosophie.
Und überhaupt kümmert sie sich
lieber um Handfestes.
Aus meiner Erfahrung mit den anderen
Häusern, die ich umgebaut habe,
macht man dann etwas,
wenn man Geld in der Kasse hat.
Und sonst nicht.
Da ich kein Freund der Banken bin
und von Abhängigkeit
im Allgemeinen,
ist das für mich stressig,
wenn es darum geht,
dass man allenfalls
einen Kredit aufnehmen müsste.
Dann habe ich ein Problem.
So.
So einfach es für Alberto war,
Philippe von einer Kreditaufnahme
zu überzeugen,
so schwierig ist es bei Eva.
Ich habe verstanden, dass wir
den Brunnen finanzieren müssen.
Aber ich habe kein Konzept gesehen.
Das macht mir Schwierigkeiten.
Ich weiss nicht,
was wir jetzt machen müssen.
Ich habe dir schon lange gesagt,
dass wir so schnell wie möglich
vermieten müssen.
Wenn man konsequent sein
und keine Schulden machen will,
oder diese so schnell wie möglich
zurückzuzahlen will,
dann muss man
nach einem Einkommen schauen.
Das hat man nur
indem man die Häuser vermietet.
Ich muss genau wissen,
bei welcher Bank und wie viel -
dann überlege ich mir das.
Werden die beiden eine Lösung finden?
In der nächsten Folge
von "Auf und davon":
Ankunft von Tochter und Enkelkindern.
Trotz Freude:
Das Verhältnis zwischen Eva und
Philippe wird immer angespannter.
Ich habe mir meine Pension ...
... etwas anders vorgestellt.
Nichts geht mehr:
In Frankreich fällt der Häcksler aus.
Das geht ins Geld.
Man organisiert Leute, die dann
stundenlang stillstehen und kosten.
Aleksandra ist stolz.
Hier wird aus unserer Milch
Butter hergestellt.
Das ist mega cool.
Und Umzug in Florida
bei hoher Arbeitsbelastung.
Mike fällt wegen Erschöpfung aus.
Mir fielen Sachen aus den Fingern,
ich hatte keine Kraft mehr.
Marina ist nun
komplett auf sich gestellt.
Einkaufen gehen
und alles alleine schleppen.
Am Abend bei Dunkelheit
den Laden schliessen, mit dem Geld.
Als er da war,
gab mir das Sicherheit.
# U si stige i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt
# und chöme nümme hei.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Michaela Hoss - 2022